Speaker 1: We're going to talk now about the
right wing media propaganda cycle.
This is not dissimilar to money laundering
in a sense, where the money starts dirty and
ends up clean.
Maybe not a perfect analogy, but let's think
through the cycle.
How does the right force nonsense and imaginary
issues into what we might call the mainstream
of the political media discussion?
The first step is get some coverage of your
crazy idea or claim somewhere, even if it
is not reporting it as if it's true.
But reporting that you said it either way
is good and it starts the propaganda cycle.
So it might start, for example, in a small
local news outlet of some kind.
Maybe you'll have a local reporter tweeting
about it, and often it will come from some
kind of small time news agency, often understaffed.
They don't have the resources to fact check
every story.
They've got tight deadlines and pressure from
editors, so they've got to pump stuff out.
So if you can plant a rumor on one of those
platforms, you're already well on your way
to starting this cycle of right wing propaganda.
And this could be, you know, there are there
are cat litter boxes in the bathrooms at some
schools for the students who identify as cats.
That's that's one possibility.
Get something written about it somewhere,
get tweets from reporters, even if it's just
it is being claimed that this is going on.
The second step is you take those tweets or
local news articles or whatever the case may
be, and you then use social media to amplify
it based on those initial bits of reporting.
You use that to generate more attention about
it, because as we know, there are so many
people on Twitter that if they see Marjorie
Taylor GREENE or whoever retweet something
that says they've got cat litter boxes in
schools for students who identify as cats,
95% of the people who see it and retweet it
won't check.
What is the original source?
My I always tell you critically analyze primary
sources to try to understand what you're being
fed.
You can use that initial thing to then amplify
it on social media, and then it'll take on
a life of its own.
Social media becomes a great breeding ground
for amplifying rumor and conspiracy theory.
Even better, if you know how to use bots and
trolls, you can get the rumors to spread like
wildfire.
And before you know it, they've gone viral
on Twitter, on Reddit, wherever the case may
be.
Step three is you want to upgrade the credibility
of the propaganda through an outlet, like
maybe an oann or a Newsmax, with the goal
of eventually getting it onto Fox News, where
the likes of Tucker Carlson can bring it up,
not yet reporting on it, but asking questions.
Right.
And this is a classic propaganda technique,
starts with some local news story based on
conjecture, amplified on social media by Republicans.
And then Tucker says, listen, we need to be
allowed to ask questions about cat button
cat litter boxes in school bathrooms.
The American people have a right to know about
cat litter boxes in bathrooms, and the left
doesn't want to talk about it.
Well, maybe the left doesn't want to talk
about it because there's no evidence that's
the third step in the cycle.
We need to be allowed to talk about this.
And if you can argue that someone is trying
to stop you from talking about it, even better,
then you get to the fourth step, which is
sort of what we saw yesterday in the hearing
from which we saw clips earlier in the show
with Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Politicians need to start demanding
answers and maybe they'll hold a hearing.
And instead of actually asking questions,
they just rant and rant and rant.
And it's all because the public has a right
to know.
And this is where these propaganda stories
can really gain momentum once politicians
get involved in a formal way.
The rumor is now a story, even if it was always
based on nothing and the media can't ignore
it.
In this case, it's about, you know, York has
lied and all these different things.
The last step is you cement the rumor for
an election cycle by just sort of keeping
it going long enough.
And that's when it becomes fact in the minds
of many people.
The longer you can keep it in the news cycle,
the more that a large portion of.
The electorate will believe that it is true.
It starts to be referred to as truth, and
then it can last an entire election cycle
or longer.
There are so many causes of this propaganda
cycle.
But Marjorie Taylor GREENE has added this
new layer, which is you just yell the conspiracy
theories that a witness to whom you're supposed
to be asking questions.
That is now the epitome of this.
So what should we do?
What can we do?
The most important thing is to understand
the cycle and remember if everybody understood.
Critically analyze primary sources before
you.
Retweet, before you fall for it, before you
start talking about it as if it's true.
If everybody understood that if we were vigilant,
if we actually tried to understand where we
are getting these claims from, we would be
able to short circuit these propaganda cycles
getting going in the first place.
Of course, due to a lack of media literacy,
hyper partizanship and lack of of education
and so much ignorance that we see, it's very
hard to short circuit it.
But this is the anatomy of that cycle.
And Marjorie Taylor GREENE sort of knows how
to take advantage of it, that's for sure.
We'll have all of the clips I played today
on our Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show and of course, on our YouTube
channel.
Make sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel YouTube.com slash The David Pakman
Show